[Music]
hey you guys what's going on it's Monday
yep and it's a haunting Mondays yep and
if you're in the United States it's the
eve of the Fourth of July yeah which
means I have the goddamn day off
tomorrow yeah and they're out there
[__] letting off fireworks yeah so
obviously they're still doing here like
a lot well they started last night
actually yeah Pookie's like what the
[__] is this I'm hiding under the bed
when uh when for the fourth of July's
happens you see our our uh our housing
community has a private golf course on
it that other people can pay come here
and use it I don't think it's free for
us is it we got to pay for it probably
yeah it's even got a little restaurant
over there that we've never been in yeah
but it's in the middle of our
neighborhood well they got fireworks
over there yeah you can see them from my
back window get up on the second floor
just watch the fireworks you don't have
to go down there
well when they do that fireworks display
last last year [__]
Pookie [__] head yeah she was hiding
looking like they're coming for me
they're not coming for you
I felt so bad yeah she had she was
hiding from the phone she was terrified
yeah
you could you could see her from and
look at you okay and she was
all right
she was scared yeah she did not like it
yeah
uh Zach said Fourth of July Side Track
show I mean we weren't planning on it
but maybe I don't know we'll see what
we're doing
because we might be doing some other
stuff for our other project yeah
me and Jan did a photo shoot
that was on a that was Saturday it's on
a Saturday yeah yeah that was Saturday
so we got done with that
oh and actually it's best Jen's best
photo shoot she looks gorgeous
I have we have I don't think we posted
any of them yet I posted three of them
on Twitter yeah okay that's like the
only three things I put on that yeah and
um
after that we just did it we decided to
do just a test stream
extreme yeah did you see how it worked
see what the interface was like so we
had the [__] this little stage type
thing set up and we were [__]
drinking already you know and we didn't
plan on work or we didn't we didn't
really plan on working or anything
yeah we just wanted to see what like
what it was like man people started
flying into the door quick
first one flew in a door is [__] just
just like like will he use the pocket
[__]
can you come
[Laughter]
and then uh Jenny got some hey beautiful
and then that guy but we were only on
for like 15 15 minutes or so well
probably 15 minutes wasn't it
maybe a bit longer than that like I said
I just wanted to see how it works yeah
we were talking so um
but it turns out like uh some like
why the [__] these dudes coming at me it
was like three three different ones huh
yeah yeah so I [__] grabbed my tablet
and I'm looking to see uh
what guys were streaming and dudes were
dogs and then if I can look to see what
couples were streaming there was only
like a couple and it was Saturday night
so what it is is all the gays started
[__] looking for dudes in the couple
sections yeah that's what it was
but uh so they were asking you for all
kinds of stuff they were asking for all
kinds of [__] no we're paying though so
you weren't paying you're not gonna do
it for free and [__] what they were
asking would have taken more time than
they had money for right they want you
to get done with that [__] in five
minutes when I get the [__] out of here
you think I am I'm not that much of a
stuck
he's trying to get [__] for free well
yeah I think that's kind of the whole
thing they're trying to scam some people
how long would it take I said it
probably been a half hour she wanted to
wanted me to get on jail and do this and
[__] the real thing I said I'm like
look man we really only do something
like that maybe during a gold show you
know that would cost a lot of money it
was a you know it you know it's at 5.99
a minute man it'd be it cost it cost you
a lot because how long would it take and
I'm like is this dude a better woman
probably about 20 minutes man [__]
half hour probably would put on a whole
[__] show and if you wanted that [__]
to be real you got it it takes time well
yeah obviously I mean we would have done
it if he paid but you know it would have
paid yeah but that would be like four or
four hundred bucks right probably maybe
five after that that would have been
good yeah like I said I mean we had been
we weren't planning on staying on long
we just went on there like to see what
it was like because we'd never done it
before and um you know just kind of see
how all the controls worked and
everything like that because I mean
we've been doing photo shoots all day
and stuff like that we were super tired
so we just kind of and we were kind of
drunk so yeah we just kind of like went
on there to see what it was like and see
if anybody came in but we did get a lot
of people coming yeah but like I said No
One's Gonna Pay and the thing about
streamate is that you can't you're not
really allowed to do anything super
explicit in the public
room you know what I mean yeah like you
can show like boobs and stuff like that
but you can't like no real below the
waist [__] no no yeah you can't do
anything like that so it's like even
some of the [__] they're asking where
you can't do that like for free you know
what I mean like on that platform you'll
get kicked off oh no that one guy said
well we can we can go exclusive it says
yeah but it's gonna take time man yeah
yeah so that's probably about 20 30
minutes is you might want to you know
and we didn't really know what the
pricing was for Block we didn't know the
system yet yeah that's why we just went
we were just like [__] you could have
like a whole block of time that you can
buy you can buy yeah an hour for a
certain but we didn't have any of that
set up right because we hadn't used that
because you get a discount if you buy a
block like if you buy 15 minutes you get
it for like you could buy an hour and
you can get quite a quite a big discount
if you buy an hour yeah but uh just
although [__] who wants to watch us walk
around for an hour I don't know maybe
somebody no they got people that are
like that yeah I guess yep because they
want to interact they want to talk and
[__] right that's true which like I said
we could do that we could do that that's
all we do on this [__] show yeah
where we're like talking about
what a dude also wanted he's wanted he
said that uh the other guy that other
one wanted to [__] um
since the ten dollars a [__] uh rate
is uh his member oh yeah that's right
they never sent the money that's yeah
because that is one thing that's on the
list that you can put up there that they
can send you a picture of their yeah
wean in your house I don't know who he
was trying to show Jen or me I don't
know
the funny thing is is that from from
other people in the business that I
heard that would that do that that
[__] have that adoption the dude's
going to send you a picture of some
[__] up
probably he doesn't want you to
compliment it he wants you well that's
what I figured pitiful it is that's what
I figure it's a humiliation like a
humiliation thing right well that's
that's what I figured because why would
a like a normal person like that was
just into normal [__] like why would
they want to send you that I don't know
yeah I kind of feel like they want you
to humiliate them yeah I think they want
to be humiliated weird which you know I
can do that yeah but yeah
come off a hamster
puberty never happened huh
well there's still time yeah but um
we're such [__] but yeah so um I'm
not really an [__] I'm kind of a nice
person now Jen's kind of mean okay but
it depends on who you are Yeah well yeah
yeah if you're nice then I'm really nice
but if you're an [__] then you're
like super mean
um all right so of course we got
distracted already yeah but like I said
we're letting people come in the door
yeah well like I said it's really nice
because I don't have to go to work
tomorrow which means that I can have a
drink I have to worry about getting up
at five [__] am yeah we're gonna have
a good fun show here for [__] The
Haunting episode yeah and this one is
well because this house is kind of
famous and I was kind of involved in
this case on the side wait were you
really how did that happen that
Paranormal Investigator talk to you oh
that's right I forgot if I was gonna
happen gonna have him on the show yeah
I'll talk to him on the phone
because man so many paranormal events
even even just in the context of this
show like this episode how many [__]
paranormal investigators like troop
through that house yeah that was the
reason why I kind of cooled off on this
case I was like there are too many
paranormal investigators involved in
this and all of them kind of say
something different and then the first
group that went in there was trying to
cause trouble and I was like
the chances are this this [__] case
is so contaminated you'll never really
know exactly what happened
um yeah it might might have really
happened but it also could be a hoax you
don't know
I kind of feel like this house maybe I
don't know how long it's had a
reputation but it's had a reputation for
being haunted I think like even before
the people yeah yeah bought it like it's
pretty famous like in that area yeah and
then buying it not knowing that it was a
famous haunted house I think
I think well that's the thing like I've
seen this house nowadays like back in
the day like before the internet like
yeah you could especially if you're
moving to another town and you were just
like oh that's a cool house and you
bought it and like nobody ever told you
anything about it but I feel like
nowadays you know you're gonna look it
up on Zillow or you're gonna look it up
on the internet like in other places and
you're gonna find out that it's famous
for being super and I've seen I've seen
the house and I've seen photographs of
the interiors and stuff this was I think
he I think uh that Paranormal
Investigator guy said I forgot his name
he's mentioned in the case what's the
guy with the white here uh Bill
something Bill something yeah I think he
sent me pictures of it online
uh I if I remember correctly he might
have been the source I did but I had
seen pictures of it
It's a Spooky look at house yeah and the
interior rooms
are we're small and kind of like a
Warren like and nonsensical a lot of
vectorian houses don't make any sense
when you go inside the the layout it's
not a modern layout
uh you got to walk through people's
rooms to get to other rooms there's a
lot of that and well you know what's
weird too is that this because I looked
this house up it has 10 bedrooms and two
and a half bathrooms yeah which is just
because it was in the time of chamber
pots yeah it's because that's that far
back yeah probably 1860s like nowadays
they usually will give you at least as
many bathrooms as there are bedrooms and
maybe one extra but yeah back then
they're like 10 bedrooms you don't need
that many bathrooms like I said
everybody bathrooms may have been added
later yeah they probably the house was
probably not built with them at all okay
we're using chamber pots
now we were wondering because this
episode came out in what 2013 2014
something like that and at the end of
this episode
um the couple at the center that had
bought the house like still owned it and
I'm not sure now the house the last time
the house was sold or actually I think
it's for sale now
um it went on sale it went on the market
at the end of 2022 and it has been
restored okay uh completely I think they
did a full restoration as far as I'm
aware like in 2021 okay
um so I saw it looked rough so I think
it's still for sale it's um I saw an
article that said it was for sale for
329 thousand dollars damn that's a good
deal which is uh that's cheaper in this
house cheap as [__] yeah yeah and it's
um the thing is those the 6600 square
feet the uh Victorian homes uh are money
eaters you just you can't heat them or
cool them
it is in Massachusetts you don't really
need cooling that much it's not like
you're down south
but they're damn near impossible to heat
I mean that one Michigan bad house that
I was in not Michigan Massachusetts bad
house me and my boy lived in it didn't
it
we it had a it had a um an oil burning
kind of like central heating system it
didn't work all that well
and uh it wouldn't get you could keep it
from not freezing inside
but there were places in that house that
were chilly as [__]
the wind had hit it you could feel the
whole [__] house Flex in the wind you
know you can feel it made a lot of noise
it creaked a lot
and uh if you look at it it's a kind of
good looking house but they're just it
was a Victorian house they're just not
they're old and they weren't they're not
made to Modern standards yeah I mean
really the only reason you would want
that is if you were into that aesthetic
and had enough money to maintain it yeah
but you'll never really have
a nice comfortable modern air controlled
climate inside there no and especially
if you want it to look like it did back
in the day which a lot of people do
because that's why they buy them they're
not gonna like modernize it out because
it would look all [__] up yeah there's
no place to put ducks or anything like
that for your air conditioning yeah
that's another thing and a lot of times
electricity was added a lot later so all
the electrical conduits on the outside
of the walls in in metal conduit there's
a lot of that
um
they're just not
real comfortable or practical
compared to say like a modern home I
mean the thing about it it's like I love
the look of them yeah but to be honest
if I had the money I would rather build
something that looked like that yeah but
was had all the modern conveniences
because right like a fake big story
house like the one like the Haunted
Mansion at [__] right that's what I
mean it's not there it's like
it's actually like a [__] facade it's
just an empty building because I yeah
because I would love a house that looked
like that but um but I don't want like
all of the no like all all the late
Victorian [__] that goes along with it
you can't get up in the middle of the
night and go go to the other side of the
house without and not wake up your
girlfriend or your wife or you could
hear somebody walk through that whole
house because those wooden floors yeah
and just it was echoey and things
[__] creaked in your crap crap you
hear footsteps all over the place you
couldn't there's no such thing as being
quiet in those houses yeah yeah doesn't
even matter how big they are
they're just kind of echoey
and what's weird is that they'll have a
lot of rooms and the rooms are small
by today's standards alone
you're like is this a bedroom
what is this what kind of room is this
it's bigger than a closet it's a little
smaller than a bedroom what is this what
was this room used for yeah and people
go I don't know the room
some kind of parlor you sat in might
have been a little kid's room at some
time you don't know they just sat in it
well like I said that's all they were
the victorians they didn't have no TV or
nothing like that they just go and sit
in this room and go sit inside
the other room to sit and talk well I
mean I said and they have friends over
and talking yeah that was their version
of Twitter having some having your
friends over talking yeah yeah
imagine that yeah I know people still do
that yeah but yeah so like I said this
house is kind of famous it's actually uh
known as the Sylvester K Pierce house or
the SK Pierce house and it was built in
it was finished in 1875.
so um so on the episode
this uh this took place in summer of
2008 they said and this isn't Gardner
Massachusetts
which is
did they say it was the furniture
capital of the world I find that hard to
believe but well I guess the it's known
for furniture manufacturing particularly
like chair manufacturing like making
wooden chairs and stuff like that that
was kind of what the big uh industry was
in the town
so the couple that we have at the center
of this in 2008
um they were from Boston and they had
been looking around for a house to buy
like in this smaller town the guy's name
is Edwin Gonzalez and his girlfriend's
name is Lillian Otero
now Lillian had always wanted a
Victorian house so when they saw this
one
um she was just completely she's like
yeah we gotta have this and it wasn't I
think they said in 2008 when they bought
it it was less than two hundred thousand
dollars I don't know what the condition
of it was
um you know because on the show
obviously it looked all beautiful and
and everything he didn't mention
anything about it needing a lot of work
or anything like that he did say that it
was like really beautiful when they
bought it and everything like that but
like I said I think they've restored it
in 2021 like back to its former glory or
whatever so and I think that whoever
owns it now or whoever owned it recently
they
um hosted as like they let uh people
stay overnight like and look for ghosts
and [__] like that so they have it kind
of like as a I don't know if it's a bed
and breakfast but they kind of like let
people stay there well during my little
preliminary investigation of this and
trying to get a guest on
um
it turns out that after after this
episode you know came out they were
still trying to have dude they were
trying to do things like ghost tours
yeah to save the mansion
now they evidently rebuilt it I don't
know if it probably wasn't them probably
somebody else did that with a loan
trying to save that house I don't think
I don't think uh ghost tours would pay
to pay enough to save a house like that
probably no no well and this house was
on like a bunch of other paranormal
shows too I think it was on like my
ghost story and yeah was it a parable
witness I can't remember I don't know
made a bet on Paranormal Witness as well
but it was on more than this one you
know what I mean that might have been a
wise investment you had that thing on
the [__] all these damn ghosts
channels it didn't cost much though but
then you uh raised the uh the money to
fix it then you sell it to somebody who
wanted a haunted house yeah and this
house like I said even though now I
don't know if it's still for sale but it
went on sale like late last year
and it's on the um
uh what do you call it on the national
register of historic uh places or
whatever they just put it on there last
year
so like I said it's kind of and they had
like famous people stayed there like
Norman Rockwell stayed there I think he
might have done a painting with this
house in it also you know Calvin
Coolidge like people like that so like
famous people stayed there you know what
I mean I'm like a lot of movie stars are
not movie stars but
um you know stage actors and stuff like
that that were famous like they stayed
there back in the day because I think
for a while it was a um it was a
boarding house like a boarding house or
an inn or something like that
because it was originally built as a
family home obviously for Sylvester K
Pierce and his family like he he had a
um
uh like a manufacturing like a chair
manufacturing uh Factory like right
across the street that he owned
so uh so yeah
so they see this house Lillian is like
yeah we gotta have this because she had
really wanted a Victorian Mansion
so they go in there and she is just like
all about it so she's taken pictures
like all around the house because she's
super excited but then kind of the first
sort of tiny little mysterious thing
that happened was that she's taking
pictures around the house and the camera
suddenly stops working now she said the
dead battery light came on even though
she had just put new batteries in it you
know what I mean which you know that's a
little bit weird but it's not that weird
but that was kind of like the first
thing that happened what's up black frog
what's up uh been a while since I caught
one of these yeah that's right it is
um
yeah Zach was uh Zach says the house I
was living as my old roommate was listed
as three bedrooms but it only had two I
think they were
um voting the open air Loft over the
living room as one isn't that false
advertising yeah I mean I guess there's
all kind of like little ways they get
around [__] you know what I mean
because I lived in a house in Daytona
that was technically
two bedrooms but somebody had built out
in the back like behind the kitchen
um I guess it used to be the screened in
porch but they had built it out into a
room
so they were considering that a bedroom
too which I guess it could have been
even though it was like double doors
like right into the kitchen which was
like kind of weird for a bedroom but I
guess you could make it a bedroom if you
wanted we actually used it for an office
but
which seemed like a better use of it
um but yeah
and then Zach said wow they listed for
329k that's not a lot is it not for a
house this size no I looked it up and
it's six thousand six hundred and sixty
one square feet this house is now 500.
yeah it went up yeah so it kind of made
money on even though we don't own it yet
yeah
but yeah so and this so this house is um
not this house but the one in the
episode like I said 10 bedrooms two and
a half baths just it goes to show you
how people don't really want to live in
victorians yeah I mean well they
probably would if they weren't such
money is there money eaters right yeah
like I said if I could have a house that
looked like that but was otherwise
modern like they had all the modern [__]
in it yeah I would totally snap that up
because I love that aesthetic I love
that look Heating and Cooling just
crossed an arm and leg Yeah it was just
they were built for that too expensive
yeah
but yeah so um so yeah the camera dies
out like with the dead battery light and
she's like huh that's weird whatever and
he's like well we're gonna buy the house
so don't worry about it you can have
plenty of pictures later on now Edwin
said though that when they were looking
around the house like prior to buying it
he said he just had really weird Vibes
about the place he's like he would go
through some of the rooms like some of
the rooms were fine and he felt totally
fine but then he would go in like one
particular room or like another room and
he'd like have a really bad feeling like
he'd feel like really nauseated
um and [__] like that so he's like and
then like the second he stepped out of
the room like he would feel totally fine
again so he thought that was a little
weird but he's like you know I didn't
like it but
um Lillian was like so excited about
this house and I wanted her to have it
so so they went ahead and bought it
and uh so yeah another weird thing that
happened is I guess they had a neighbor
or like a friend of theirs that lived
next door
and this guy is apparently like jogging
past their house
and he sees a little boy in the upstairs
window like he kind of saw the kid
he kind of explained it as he saw the
kid like going from one window to the
other and then all of a sudden he'd be
like there were two windows on this
other side of the house too and he'd see
the kid like running back and forth
between the windows but then like he'd
be over here on this side of the house
and like Edwin is like well that can't
happen because there's like walls and
yeah rooms are halls and stuff those two
rooms aren't connected so you wouldn't
be able to like get there even if that
was like a real kid but it's like so he
goes down like the the guys like jogging
past he's like what the [__] and then he
asked Edwin he's like I didn't think you
guys had any kids and he's like we don't
and he's like well who's that little boy
like up in the window all the time he's
like she beats me I don't know
um you know what I mean so yeah so
apparently more than one person I think
saw a little kid up in the window and
that's like a pretty common thing that
had been reported too by other people
like people just walking past
so
um apparently the first few weeks after
they moved in kind of went by sort of
quietly
but then they're sleeping one night
and the sheets kind of get pulled off
them like that now I'm not really sure
how because they showed in the
reenactment that they didn't wake up
when this happened
it's like the sheets like like starts
pulling off them like that what woke
them up was the door slamming the
bedroom door slammed by itself
and of course they thought somebody was
in the house because that's what you
would think so Edwin gets up and like
freaking out and he like goes out there
but there's like nobody out in the
hallway there's nobody in the house so
the door just kind of slammed by itself
and then apparently later on that same
night it's five o'clock in the morning
even though on the reenactment it was
like bright daylight outside I'm like in
what universe is a bright daylight at
5am
like especially in Massachusetts
so 5 a.m the doorbell rings
and they're like who the [__] is that
like at five o'clock in the morning
they're like oh well maybe it was some
contractor that was like not five a
[__] clock in the morning that'd be
rude and then they there's like pounding
on the door like somebody's pounding and
pounding pounding and he's like what the
[__] so like he goes down there and
opens the door and again nobody there so
doorbell ringing and pounding on the
door we had that happening not pounding
but we had the doorbell ring yeah in the
middle of the night at our place
um it was like 4 30. yeah you said it
ran twice yeah I always slept through it
you woke me up yeah yeah cause I was
freaking out
a few nights after that uh Edwin is in
the home office and straight up sees an
apparition of a dude I don't know if it
was like a full body Apparition like the
way they showed it in the thing it
seemed like kind of part of his face and
maybe like part of his torso or whatever
so at this point this kind of freaks him
out
as it would so he calls the previous
owner to ask about you know hey did you
guys experience anything weird in this
house and [__] like that
and the guy said oh didn't anybody tell
you which is always something that like
whenever this happens and these episodes
and then you call like the previous
owner didn't anyone tell you they always
say that
so the guy talked about the history of
the house he's like oh by the way a dude
burned to death in the master bedroom
like years ago you know what I mean he's
like oh that's awesome
and then uh somebody pointed him to a
book called Haunted Massachusetts which
was written by a guy named Thomas
Agostino I think they said was his last
name
and uh he goes to the library or the
bookstore or whatever and like looks in
this book and his house is in it and
he's like oh [__] well that's probably
not good
so like I said they they talked a little
bit about the history of Sylvester K
Pierce he had the house built for his
family back in 1875 and his wife died in
the house apparently like only less than
a year after moving in
and then eventually like the sons took
over and then it became a boarding house
now the guy that burned to death the
story about it was he was a tenant when
the place was a boarding house and I
guess he was 48 years old they said what
his name was it was Ian of something but
I couldn't remember what his last name
was
um and yeah they just found him the
house didn't burn down or nothing like
that so the legend started going around
that he had died from like spontaneous
combustion you know what I mean because
he just like burned to death in the room
and I don't know if nothing else in the
place was burned or if it wasn't that
damaged or something like that but there
was a legend circulating that he had
died of spontaneous combustion even
though I don't believe that he probably
just
fell asleep with a cigarette in his hand
and burned up on the Montage
combustion's been to Bucks many times it
has yeah and when you I saw a
reenactment of it when you see the fire
you go oh of course it
if you take a carpet anything that can
allow airflow underneath the body
and you can take a pig and put it on the
carpet
especially if you have a blanket or a
little bit of clothes on the pig
and then just take a
a match or a or a lighter and just catch
the clothes on fire or maybe even just
the carpet
that flame
will get up against the Flash
and it'll just start to burn
the whole body will slowly over time
it burns like the way a candle burns you
know the Flames don't get any any higher
and four or five inches
and it doesn't burn down the rest of the
house or anything the flames never get
big yeah and it just kind of starts in
that one spot slow slowly spreads across
the body in a ring and then goes down
then when it gets to the hands and the
feet it goes out there's not enough fat
there to fuel it right it happens with
fat people or people that have fat in it
is more likely because the fat is
getting up on the dam
clothing or the carpet or the bed sheets
or whatever
the melted Fat's getting in there and
then it's burning on the damn clothes
like a wick yeah a wick on a candle or a
wick on a damn lamp
like a like a like a like an oil lamp
yeah and it
and it'll turn the bone to Ash and
everything it'll shrink skulls it'll
[__] look bizarre it'll look like it
was a real high temperature
fire but it wasn't it was a very low
temperature slow burning fire like a
crock pot worse but you know how crock
pot cooked meat real slow
that's what will happen to you
and there's always somebody died of a
heart attack while they're smoking yeah
while they're laying in bed or they drop
they drop and they [__]
die while they're drunk or they're
[__] just pass out drunk and then the
fire and the smoke inhalation kills them
yeah you would think that the fire would
wake them up but they tend to be
overweight they tend to be alcoholics
I don't know if they burn to death alive
I would think no
I think they just happen to have a heart
attack whether yeah I mean especially if
the especially if the fire burned that
slowly you'd think that you'd be like
even as drunk as you were you'd be like
Jesus Christ what the [__] is going on
well you would think that but people
have gotten so drunk they've passed out
in the bathtub and drowned that's true
like that girl from cranberries that
cute little Irish girl yeah
I'm Irish people man y'all need to keep
it under control
we're not that bad we're drinking in the
bathtub [__] drowning and say oh [__]
it I mean I'm not [__] I'm drowning
yes
I'm
not gonna take a bath when I've been
drinking yes one thing because I'm kind
of paranoid about that kind of [__]
Zach says Ino sorry was his name thank
you yeah I knew they said what his name
was but I couldn't I knew I wrote down
his first name but not his last name
because I didn't hear it uh a Finnish
immigrant apparently yeah so he burned a
death in this house and I guess that and
I guess that is documented yeah like I
don't think he's spontaneously combusted
but he did he did burn to death I
haven't seen Poltergeist
personally
I was really fascinated with spontaneous
combustion because I thought maybe it
might have been a link
I thought it might have had something to
do with pyrokinesis
which is it's like it's like rspk it's
like telekinesis but instead of moving a
large objects you're moving real small
objects molecules to create fire
I thought it might have been something
like that maybe a person burned
themselves up using pyrokinesis
but it didn't it doesn't match they're
all usually older people who are
overweight they smoke and they drink and
they're in bad shape
that's who spontaneously combust low
energy people okay it's because they die
while they're smoking and they just
throw it up yeah like you said it smells
like now there was a young person that
did that
they tried to crack that case
dude it broke into her house
and evidently raped and killed her
and she was found spot with the same
signs of spontaneous combustion
does she look like a spontaneous they
first thought it was [__] spontaneous
combustion
it wasn't it was murder and rape
what he had done
because he went into the bathroom and
grabbed some perfume and and and and and
threw it on her because they've had a
bottle of perfume there and set her on
fire with some perfume and left she was
already dead yeah
and the Flames just burned like I
described they only got like five inches
high and they burned her over a long
period of time
but the guy who went to prison that they
caught
said no I just threw him when they said
what happened he says I just threw
perfume on her and set it on fire she
was already dead
that happens a lot like it's just like
when a dude breaks into somebody's house
and like rapes and kills somebody and
then they try to set the body on fire
yeah he's trying to hide evidence right
that happens a lot yeah it didn't it
caught him anyway yeah but they were
paranormal investigators were [__]
really interested in that fire and they
just threw his testimony they realized
that it wasn't spontaneous combustion
right
Ben says perfume is flammable yeah yeah
it is yeah got a lot of alcohol in it
yeah and oil yeah and he wasn't the
brightest candle all right he just went
through some
some cleaning or some kind of product
whatever product he could get on there
and set it on fire
and it just burned a little bit like
like furnace the the the Flaming about
about as high as the flame on a lighter
and it just turned her into a dam
candle yeah
yeah like I said they've done
reenactment reenactments with like with
pig cartes as soon as you see it and as
soon as you see it it like becomes
really awesome oh yeah it's not weird
it's not weird you go because you've
seen that kind of fire before right like
a smoldering campfire yeah it's called
it yeah it's kind of like that except a
person which is horrifying but yeah
that's how it happens
so uh so yeah
so they're so they're like well that was
at least one person they they know I
think I was reading an article that said
that there are actually seven confirmed
deaths in this house
um but that was kind of the most splashy
one I guess uh the guy that burned to
death
so at one point uh Lillian is home by
herself and the door opens by itself
that seemed to happen a lot
and then they did okay they didn't do
like a real good job of like doing a
reenactment of this or maybe it's just
because I'm deaf and I didn't hear what
was going on because I'm like she seemed
like she was looking up
over
um you know this uh the high boy or
whatever kind of thing they had up there
like they had all the dishes and [__] in
it and she's like looking up there I'm
like what is she looking at like I don't
see anything up there but like when they
were talking about it later because she
wasn't the real person she wasn't
actually on the show they explained at
the end like Edwin was but he explained
at the end that it's like she's still
scared of that [__] and she didn't
really want to talk about it so so he
was kind of like talking about like what
she had told him because she didn't want
to be on the show but they explained
that actually she had heard something
growling at her from up there so I don't
know she actually hurt like saw anything
because they didn't really show anything
up there I didn't see anything anyway
but then they explained later that she
had heard something growling up there or
she felt like something was up there
so she tells Edwin about it because it's
freaking her out and he's like okay well
we really need to like get some help in
here and get somebody in here to see
what's going on so he goes and contacts
the guy that wrote the book like haunted
Massachusetts
and uh so Thomas is like he's Thomas
Agostino or whatever his name is and
he's like okay well I'll come out and do
like a you know an investigation on the
house so he comes with his wife Arlene
who of course is a medium so they do
tarot and EVPs and all that kind of
stuff now there's apparently they have
all these uh cameras and [__] like set
up all around the house
and in the reenactment they showed like
a shadow figure like going across the
camera like like that like nobody said
they saw that but they just showed that
on the reenactment but they said that
the camera on the tripod that was in the
master bedroom like it looked like
somebody had kicked it over you know
what I mean like they heard a noise and
they ran in there but that could have
just fallen over you know what I mean
I'm just saying
so they did like a cleansing with the
sage and banishing the negativity and
all that and then he tells Edwin and
Lillian he's like you have to do that
every night and everything should be
gold
a few nights after that
uh they start hearing footsteps around
the house
um then the door starts kind of opening
and slamming and stuff like that so
they're both awake and there's like what
the [__] is going on and then I thought
this was kind of interesting they
started here they heard something glass
breaking in the kitchen like it sounded
like a crystal bowl or something like
that like falling on the floor and
they're like what the [__] is going on
and then they said they kept hearing
glass breaking like somebody was just
going through and like throwing all of
their glassware like on the floor like
it sounded like that and it just kept
happening and they're just like what the
[__] so then they go down there to the
kitchen but when they go in the kitchen
nothing is wrong like nothing is broken
or nothing they're like we just heard
the noise like over and over like really
distinctly of glass breaking over and
over
now this is the this I thought this was
kind of funny so this was the dude you
were talking about his name's bill I
can't remember oh yeah yeah what's his
last name I don't remember I thought I
wrote it down but I guess I didn't yeah
because I tried it like I said I'm
trying he's a real nice guy yeah he's
yeah he's like a nice dude because the
real guy was uh yeah on the show as well
I didn't reject the case it didn't have
him on because of him I didn't have it
on because
at the time I was
we it would be a case that I could
actually have on now but at that time we
were looking for like some of the best
type Poltergeist cases that had like
evidence and [__] and best Ghost type
cases that had a lot of impartial
Witnesses this one doesn't have a lot of
impartial Witnesses
like the cops don't show up and go yeah
yeah we saw some [__] that doesn't exist
in this that's what I was looking for at
the time
but yeah apparently this bill dude
showed up just like randomly he likes I
think he called but yeah so he just
shows up on the doorstep like hi I'm
bill
um I am a spiritual empath and he was
apparently friends with the previous
owner and he had been over to the house
a bunch of times yeah
uh and he was from what based on memory
this was his favorite house
this is his favorite haunted house he
got the most action out of this house so
he was constantly keeping an eye on it
wanted to know who bought it so it's not
strange yeah he shows up he was waiting
to see who's going to buy it yeah
because you want to get back in there
I believed him
like I said he seemed like a nice man
they actually had the real guy on there
yeah uh his methods though kind of like
Airy fairy elves and Magic kind of to me
that's what kind of I'm not big into the
you know
I mean I've seen the [__] I don't but I
don't believe in like
Ouija boards and [__] uh uh magic or
you know it's not going to be like that
there's a there's a a scientific
explanation for paranormal stuff it's
just a science that we don't understand
yet
yeah so Bill shows up and he tells Edwin
he's like the whole thing he's like I've
been in this house like lots of times
and he's like there's a lot of spirits
in this house but the main one is this
woman named Maggie and Maggie was
apparently
um Sylvester Pierce's Nanny like that
was the guy that had the house built and
um so she's apparently like protecting
the house and he's like she's kind of
like the protective spirit and keeping
all the other ghosts from like acting up
you know what I mean
and he says did you ever consider like
before you bought or before the previous
owner bought it I guess was what he was
saying
the house was empty for 20 years and
he's like didn't you think it was weird
that the house was empty for 20 years
and there was no vandalism and he's like
that's because Maggie the ghost was
protecting it like keeping people from
so I don't know if she would [__] people
up if they came in there with like okay
in a spray paint or whatever I'm of the
the this is the thing see I'm of the
thinking that ghosts are rare
that into this portal thing where
there's ten ghosts living there because
it's a portal you know what I mean one
of them I just find that artistically
statistically unlikely I've seen the
Poltergeist and I've been in a bad house
before had near-death experience as an
out-of-body experience
if there's a ghost and I've never seen a
ghost ghost in the classic description
of a ghost there are apparitions and
[__]
I would think that they would be very
rare and the chances are being more than
one in one area nah
if now if you thought there was more
than one I'd be
more apt to believe what the Exorcist
said out of the damn X the movie The
Exorcist that there's just one demon is
pretending to be all these other but
there's just one
you know that's be more likely
yeah if there's a bunch of ghosts
there's more likely it's just one ghost
and pretending to be a bunch of them
because what else are you gonna do when
you're a ghost it's probably really
boring yeah
but uh but yeah so supposedly this ghost
Maggie has like been protecting this
house all this time now Bill said that
there were a couple of kind of like more
questionable or like nasty kind of
spirits in the house as well Ben says
the ghosts are Tom Sharon in the demo
all right yeah yeah it's like a sublet
yeah
um
that's what it is yeah but um he said
that there's a kid ghost in there
um who was abused as a child like when
he was alive
and he also thinks that whoever his
abuser was is also still in the house as
a ghost
um and also he said there's kind of like
a nasty ghost in the basement and a like
another nasty one on the second floor
now even after Bill tells Edwin and Lily
and all of this they still want to stay
in the house because you know this is
kind of like their dream house or
whatever
so after 10 months they decide what
they're going to do is they're going to
have like they're essentially gonna hold
like an open house for paranormal
investigators like to come in there
and see if they can get somebody that'll
help them out
so this one investigator whose name is
John breitman he's the one that
coordinates everybody coming there and
he like has a specific rule nobody bring
Ouija boards like I guess he puts it on
the flyer or from the invitation or
something like that he's always like
nobody bring Ouija boards God damn it
but you know how like nobody listens
so a bunch of different paranormal teams
come and they all set up in different
rooms and like try with their equipment
or whatever and they're trying to kind
of get
evidence or what have you
however you always just knew it's always
the Goths like I said blame the guys
sacrifice of cats
or right we're the worst but um yeah
I I would never I would turn a fan on oh
okay
okay the show's biggest fan yeah
sorry that was terrible
um but yeah
anyways I stole that joke from MST so um
because that's actually what I was
thinking of but uh so yeah so they all
set up in different rooms but one
goddamn satanic couple sneaks in a paper
Ouija board I guess they just kind of
folded it up and they were like tee he
like put it in their [__] jeans
Pockets or whatever or the pocket in
their cloak or whatever they were skinny
jeans too well yeah let's see I'm just
kidding the stages wearing skinny jeans
a little [__] yeah little [__]
All-Stars
and they go down to the basement with
their little paper paper Ouija board and
they're all just down there chanting and
blah blah blah satanis yada yada
whatever yeah so my father plays Domino
better than your father please don't
that's what they're saying
my Padre plays dominoes better than your
Padre plays dominoes okay yeah
but yeah so they don't really bring I
don't know I guess they kind of imply
that these little miscreants with the
paper Ouija board that they're the ones
that kind of cause the trouble that went
on later with Lillian and stuff but they
don't really like mention them again
really
so the guy that coordinated it he has
one of those what's that thing called an
ovulus that kind of that [__] okay
it does actually it kind of it does
sound like get your hands off my Oculus
do you know how much that costs
foreign
[Laughter]
no no that's no that's the flashlight
that's the planchette that's the plan
[__] the obvious thing is the [__]
thing that like spits out words that
just like Scrolls through them it
Scrolls their radio frequencies yeah and
you ask it questions and then it just
like spits out words yeah
Zach says obvious side effects may
include
anal leakage but um yeah yeah
I mean you know
we were watching YouTube the other day
and a commercial came on for some kind
of medicine and everything is said we
were like what what you know and it may
also cause your head to explode cause
your intestines to come out
I was like I ain't taking that [__] it
was a long list it's like a long list of
bad [__] could happen to you if you take
this medicine
I'm like hey taking that [__] what made
them think they would even sell
well that's the thing I think I think
the medication was for bipolar disorder
right yeah I was like nah thanks I'll
keep the bipolar yeah like after that
list of [__] I was like Jesus [__]
Christ no thank you it wasn't worth it
no it really wasn't I mean if your
bipolar is really bad maybe it is but I
kind of feel like for most people I'll
be like no thanks I'll just I'll just
keep I don't wouldn't take most of the
medicines and people [__] they're
trying to sell they're just trying to
sell you patented medicine just like
back in the day snake oil they're gonna
have [__] rattlesnake heads in the
jar it's that same [__]
when they probably had a cure for that
long time ago but they don't want to
talk about it because they're on the
patent on it I mean I try not to take
anything unless I absolutely have to you
know what I mean
but
I know not everybody is as lucky as I am
but I have a really good immune system
that's like I just I just won the
genetic Lottery there hormone therapy
[__] solves a lot of problems
diabetes and [__] high blood pressure
good
but yeah so the obvious thing that just
goes through and goes crap
and then like you just interpret listen
it answered my question yeah no it did
so anyways what this guy decides to do
this part was kind of funny to me too he
decides he's gonna go into I guess the
master bedroom where that's he burned to
death and he's going to try and provoke
the ghost into like saying something
right so he's like hey you know like
because I think that was his name and
he's like I heard that you don't like
people sitting on your bed woman sitting
on your bed [__] even if you
didn't say that but like he's just like
sitting on there maybe I'll even spend
the night how do you feel about that
like I even wrote about my I wrote my
notes how you like that ghosty that's
what I wrote that he didn't say that
though
so I guess you know did not like it not
one bit because uh Brightman gets his Le
he gets the the trademark like three
scratches like on his side right he's
like oh it got me you know what I mean
and then they lift up and he's got like
three scratches on there so I was like
ghost got you and then uh the ghost said
some scary [__] like over the over the
obvious which now I'm never gonna be
able to think of that the same way
sexual as [__]
well yeah because it sounds like
ovulation yeah yeah why did they call it
an ovulus they're illiterate
they're [__]
Santa cool yeah posting on his mind
like that it's the obvious that's
thank you
it's ovulating right now let's get it
pregnant it's not it's obvious it's
obvious that is
up
yeah it'll make all kinds
laughs
that's probably exactly how that went
down I'm not sure it was they got some
chick with them she goes that sounds
great you pass the joint
don't fogart that man yes yeah black
frog said is the ghost's first name
Brian see that was the first thing I
thought of actually his first name is
eno he's like or Ino or I know I can't
remember what they said I think they
said you know
but yeah I was thinking like brandy you
know okay
um but yeah so so the ghost like
scratches aside and then scarce says
some scary [__] like over the Obelisk
apparently he said what they say he said
squeeze every throat in this house yeah
I'm gonna squeeze every throat that's
what he said like and they said it was
like pretty clear like an all growly
like a demon like yeah you know like
like a dancing voice yeah I'm gonna
squeeze every throat is out
I was doing Mississippi delta blues
man
that goes here
around your throat
oh yeah all right
high testosterone Brothers back in
Mississippi in the 1930s dude you should
make a whole record like yeah like a
delta blues record but it's all about
paranormal [__] that would be awesome I
don't think anybody's ever done that
have they got that ghost up in my booty
you can smell it for miles away
it's just evil spirits
oh my God
and then one side joke we're gonna fart
and I'm going man
evil spirits and [__] well yeah we make
all kind of joke about that like we're
sitting we're sitting on the bed
watching a movie or something and all of
a sudden he doesn't even say anything
and all of a sudden it'll just like and
I'm like Jesus Christ like chemical
warfare
and then he's like
and I'm just like you [__] you
never can't tell when it's gonna be bad
and then I have to like run in the other
room and get the and then I should come
and run in the room for Febreze then I'm
like
and I'm like yeah come on
it's crazy
it's like an Absolution with the Febreze
we are in a show why are we talking
about this we're talking about evil
spirits yeah it's true they come out
your ass yes where else would they come
out of well pretty much yeah I just I
think it would be really funny for you
to do a record like that like going to
have a colonoscopy yeah and they look in
there and it looks like a damn burned up
charcoal grill
some evil spirits have been through here
yeah it's like the bowels of hell
foreign
oh I forgot too that the ghost also
punched this dude in the face because it
gave him a black eye yeah I remember
that might be the only documented case
of like a ghost just like popping
somebody right in the [__] giving him
a Shiner gotta say I didn't buy it
yeah I don't really buying a ghost
giving you a black eye I mean that's a
little far-fetched
how would a ghost even hit you with a
fist
ghosts don't have Fizz well yeah they
don't have fish that has but you know
the [__] Poltergeist can move an
object
I just it wasn't it wasn't what he
reported it's I'm not I'm not sure that
witness was credible
although you know what I mean if I can I
wasn't there yeah this has to be a kind
of situation where you had to be there
I wonder there's a lot of [__] that I
saw
up in Mammoth if you weren't there you
wouldn't believe it right yeah I mean
because they remembered more than I did
because they don't live here they lived
in California they remember they
remembered more about it than I did they
were adults I was only like 13.
black frog says ghost punch that sounds
like it'd be a cool band name
I don't know is that there's something
just inherently funny to me about a
ghost just like sacking you in the face
you know what I mean Halloween drink
mixer ghost punch ghost punch
it's like Ecto Cooler like that thing
they sold in the 80s yeah
wild berry
ghost Berry
well they already made blueberry yeah
which is gross as [__]
I liked all the [__] couch the
[__] monster cereals count chocolate
was okay I like to Frankenberry I just
like the boxes I didn't like the actual
cereal you know what I mean I like them
all I like [__] Cookie Crisp too oh
crisp Cookie Crisp was the [__] cookie
Jarvis and all that [__] do they even
make Cookie Crisp anymore why not man
that was that was good I even liked a
crazy one called Freaky tree
that doesn't sound like a food it was
[__] cereal
yeah cool I told you about coogle yeah
that also does not sound like Google was
fake peanut butter flavored
yeah I remember that Google sounds like
some exercises you do to tighten your
Hooch muscles yeah yeah Jen does this
[Laughter]
like whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa hold on
hold on to something it really works it
pulled in
is that gravitational
that gravitational oh my God we should
do a stream like that one night we'll do
that that'll be the theme yeah
gravitational pull
we just fake it for like an hour just
get the angle right in our back there
like a whoa
what I'm holding it's like a wind
blowing me in you know oh my God I wish
I was good enough at special effects
that we can make a video that actually
like it that I could like actually suck
you in there entirely it would be
awesome we'll just do it in public and
we'll just get tips
[Laughter]
I'm gonna just do a comedy stream like
that well I mean it's us so it's gonna
end up being comedy no matter what we do
you know what I mean we can't help
ourselves we can't help ourselves
because we're just like [__] smart
asses and we can't take a single thing
seriously
you know what I mean but that's okay
uh so yeah so after the two gets punched
by the ghost
um you know everybody he's like okay
everybody clear out this like shit's not
funny anymore right
so now after this Edwin's like okay
we're not doing like Paranormal open
house anymore this is like some [__]
it's like apparently all the ghosts got
provoked we had Satanist with paper
Ouija boards there was like a whole
situation
so Edwin is like so now I'm still gonna
let paranormal investigators in the
house
but they have to be like friends of mine
like beforehand and then like another
one comes in who's a friend of his name
Bob and I'm like how many [__]
paranormal investigators is this dude no
Jesus it was a lot you know because he
was like another one and I was like oh
this is a different guy all right he
must have hung out in a circle he that's
what I'm thinking like because I was
like no normal person knows that many
paranormal investigators you don't have
the same bar the Paranormal Investigator
bar yeah that's where you know that they
have the cop bar that they have the pair
then they have the Ghost Hunter bar yeah
the ghost on her bar they all go there
to talk shop you know what I mean
uh but yeah so so Bob the Paranormal
Investigator and Edwin are down in the
basement and there's this kind of Kiln
oven thing down there which I guess it's
not like all intact or everything but
it's just like brick
and they find the paper Ouija board and
they're like aha like this is maybe what
caused it I don't know that was kind of
like the implication anyway
um and then they're going back up what
what are you laughing at don't worry
about it's all about there oh okay
just dawned on me if I can we're talking
about this
y'all are gonna trip this only happens
to [__] me in my life
oh [__] this should be good
on a stream mate you have the ability to
sell videos on there we already got a
bunch of them approved they're up there
I've arranged Jen's first girl girl
scene oh that's what you were thinking
about okay with my ex-girlfriend
what she's my friend too yeah yeah they
like each other I love her but it's
funny how like yeah that's my girlfriend
and my ex
and look I'm not rich I don't have a
[__] ton of money it's just it's just
that they have pride dudes out there
that paid millions of dollars for that
experience it was just they probably was
they do [__] too they kind of create
content
her and her husband her and her husband
yeah and I he's a friend of ours too I
introduced them yeah a long time ago
they've actually been together yeah well
slightly longer than us yeah and uh they
go down to secrets and [__] they're
they're like open swinger couple now
basically
but uh no she's like uh I [__] talked
to him and I was like I was showing him
some of the material making oh yeah it's
good and he's showing me [__] that
[__] they're making
and I'm like uh dude we got to get
[__] Jen Jen and Olay together julaid
is cute okay you guys I've shown
pictures of her before
so we've got to get them together man
and [__] the great girl girl scene to
be he's like oh yeah man and then we can
trade him up and I was like
he's like that yeah he's like that what
you're talking about this is 20
Questions Advantage this is 2023.
yeah he's trying to get at you
but anyway uh
I just think that shit's [__] funny
in there that's what you're thinking
yeah well now it just dawned on me I was
like oh [__] I just realized that I
[__] hooked I hooked this [__] up
between my girlfriend and my ex yeah you
did yeah okay and you didn't tell me
ahead of time that you were doing that
well no it's just something it's just
open I wanted to see if they yeah they
would say yeah they say yeah because
like I said we you know yeah and she
doesn't want to stream like she doesn't
want to live stream no first she thought
she wanted you to you guys to stream
Together live she doesn't like live she
did ChatterBait for a while yeah she
hated it
well I've heard ChatterBait is kind of a
[__] show yeah I mean it's like what she
saw on the street in the front right
yeah yeah like people are kind of
[__] yeah well streamate is better
because it's like it's a little bit
curated and there's only like paying
customers but yeah I've heard
ChatterBait is like some people like
that but
like having thousands of people like
watching you yeah
and like some of them are abusive and
chilly yeah but that's another [__] 2
000 people watching and only four are
paying right
so it's like that's not not really my
thing yeah not really my thing I would
rather like a smaller crowd yeah that
was more yeah you might as well regulate
not a damn [__] Roman Arena yeah no
thanks which they did that evidently
yeah live sex in the middle of the Roman
Arena imagine that it's before before
the games yeah and they're pretty
probably everybody was like throwing
[__] at you and everything like that hey
see if you can hit him some historians
say it was all different events and [__]
[__] acrobats and [__] then live
sex and then women with animals and
[__] videos and it was it was weird
yeah that sounds about Romans were
[__] and they were and the Romans
weren't above children too I mean they I
think the children that doesn't surprise
me yeah
so yeah so uh where was I so they found
this paper Ouija board and think oh
maybe this is the cause of the trouble
right or this piece of paper with Ouija
board [__] on it and so while they're
going back up from the basement Edwin
said that he felt like a finger like
down the back of his neck like really
distinctly
now uh also Bob hangs out on the second
floor
and
he there's like a door comes open by
itself
and then he sees pretty much a full body
Apparition of a woman and we kind of
laughed because because Tom's like and
he sees the ghost of Andy because it
looks like our friend yeah and I laughed
because I knew immediately Zach says he
used like a cereal that looked like a
little what does it look like a little
Waffle you talked about that what was
that what was the name of that one
something or the honeycomb she honeycomb
kind of looked like a waffle well they
had one called waffles as well waffles
and then they were Cinnamon Toast Crunch
it kind of looked a little bit like a
wall that's it that looks more like just
a little square yeah square but it had
to head little dots and like a wall
speaking of which this past weekend for
Tom's birthday we went to Ichiban yeah
buffet and then we went to books a
million and we went to the um to the
coffee shop over there yeah and the and
the Barista she made yeah Cinnamon Toast
Crunch cold brew yeah man that [__] was
delicious we're gonna go there tomorrow
it might is it open it's a holiday it's
a holiday because I wouldn't mind going
to [__] Ichiban and then getting
another one of those well we'll check
before we drive all the way over there
because I want some more shrimp because
the thing is like it's Fourth of July
but like not everything closes on the
fourth of July you know what I mean
we'll check before we go over there
waffle crisp haven't had that in ages
yet I used to really like one called
waffles which is like little they look
like little square waffles and that [__]
was delicious it tastes like maple syrup
but um they haven't made that for years
so yeah so Bob sees this Apparition and
freaks the [__] out uh and basically
like he it looks like he just kind of
like spaces out like he's not talking
and they can't they're like hello Ursa
Bob you know what I mean kind of thing
um and he basically said afterward that
he said he totally froze and he couldn't
move and Edwin had to like help him down
the stairs and he doesn't actually come
out of it until Lillian kind of like
touches him and you know is like hey are
you in there or whatever and he's just
like oh yeah I guess I'm okay but he's
like yeah I'm getting the [__] out of
this house that was [__] freaky
so uh later on Lillian who was alone in
the house and also saw
the ghosts that look like our friend
Andy as well and I guess what happened
here was it looked like it kind of like
pulled her back forcefully or like went
inside her body or something like that I
don't know if they were trying to apply
the possessed her or whatever
and so she was home by herself then but
like then Edwin comes home and sees her
lying on the couch and she's acting kind
of weird and like lethargic and he's
like why don't you come up to bed and
she's like no I'm gonna stay down here
so she just like stays on the couch and
then he's like after that she started
getting really withdrawn really unstable
really depressed like tired all the time
[__] like that like she just wasn't the
same as she was
now Edwin also sees like he's walking
down the stairs and he sees uh a girl
like in a Victorian dress or like a
woman standing in the window and she
like turns around and looks at him and
he said that she felt it felt like
really sad like he could feel like all
this grief and stuff like that like
coming off of her like this girl that
she thought that he saw
so at this point he decides he's going
to call an exorcist so this is so many
like paranormal investigators and stuff
like that trooping through this house
but he calls it an exorcist
and then you know the Exorcist comes in
and does his little little magic tricks
or whatever and puts like little crosses
in the window and [__] like that then
he's like okay your house is clean my
job here is done yada yada and then he
leaves now a few days go by and nothing
happens so they think oh well The
Exorcist actually did do the job and
everything's fine but then a couple days
later Edwin goes down to the basement
and finds Lillian down there digging in
the dirt like where the Kiln Brick Oven
thing is and she is just like flipping
out and she's just like screaming is
like let me finish leave me alone and
she's like [__] wigging the [__]
he's like what the hell is your [__]
problem Jack confirmed that it was
Waffle Chris oh okay waffle crisp yeah
they're updating people who don't have
the live chat
because
a lot of people listen to the show
recorded yeah no the regulars in the
live chat about Dave y'all are famous
you know
yeah
yeah they can't make the live show but
they they know they they remember us
talking about the Zach you know well
that's why I mean I usually do try to
like read people's comments if you know
what I mean I can't read everybody's
because you know it would just be that
but yeah I do try to because I do keep
that in mind that like maybe if you're
just listening
and the other ones they everybody the
people who listen listen to the show
recorded [__] know you're good know
your names yeah
so she's digging around in here in the
dirt and she comes up with a news
clipping
and in this news clipping which was
apparently buried in the dirt or
whatever
I guess it's talking about a bunch of
kids that drowned on the property now
they didn't really drill down into this
which I'm kind of like well wait a
minute they drowned on the property like
in the bathtub or where like it didn't
look like it was on a lake or any they
didn't mention that
and so I don't know if these kids
drowned before the house was built in
1875 or is there a flood yeah or
something I just I don't really need a
hurricane in Massachusetts no unless it
was like really really uh weird
anomalous but yeah so and they didn't
really go back to that either so I was
like that seems like a weird thing to
like just bring up and not bring up
again but okay
so that was what it was in the news
clipping
so then later on they showed them like
sleeping and then there's like the ghost
coming at them or whatever although I
don't know if they saw that or not
a few nights later bill is up again
without calling
yeah but I was like goddamn Bill don't
you know how to use a phone he just
keeps like turning up on their doorstep
hi sorry I'm just kind of like and it's
I think it was like kind of late I don't
know how late it was but he did say like
in the reenactment he's like I'm sorry
it's so late but he's like I I felt too
bad like I had to come over and tell you
because I think that Lillian is in
trouble or is in danger and I had to
come over and tell you like right away
and he said when he came in the house he
thinks what happened is that they didn't
say this outright but they think that
like the Exorcist that came that
cleansed the house actually cleansed
Maggie who was the guardian spirit and
so now all of the bad ones can just like
run roughshod over the whole entire
house because Maggie went into the light
or whatever the hell and so she's not
around to like keep them all in check
anymore
that's kind of like the implication so
Bill said now that Maggie is gone he's
like I used to actually really like this
house and like coming to this house when
his friend used to own it but he's like
now that Maggie is gone he's like I was
scared of the house like for the first
time ever because she's not there
anymore like keeping track of [__] you
know what I mean
and then he goes in to see Lillian and
she's like sitting there in the chair
and um at this point
Tom being Tom
um says about the actress he's like he's
like Lillian you have really really nice
implants you know what I mean because he
was doing like Bill like talking to her
and stuff like that how are you doing
Lily and you have really nice implants
she did actually the actress had really
nice implants they were very nicely
shaped but um but so yeah
so Lillian's sitting there in the chair
and I guess they show like her face
changes like the ghost's face is like
imposed over her face or whatever and
then like they see or bill says that he
saw like the ghost
of the woman that Bob had seen earlier
like standing behind her like with her
hand on her shoulder so the implication
being that Lillian is either kind of
possessed or being controlled by this
ghost or whatever so Lillian starts
getting all [__] angry and
her and Edwin are like fighting all the
time and she's you know like I said
she's just not the way she used to be
and then bill says you know the couple
that he was friends with that lived
there prior to Edwin and Lillian moving
in it's like they lived here for two
years and it's like they broke up at the
end because this a similar kind of thing
happened to her like I guess somebody
like kind of possessed one of the ghost
possess her and she started acting all
crazy and they broke up or whatever
so uh Bill basically says you need to
find something to believe in to protect
yourself because Maggie isn't here to
protect you anymore
um or this house is just gonna tear you
down you're gonna end up like breaking
up and and whatever
so at this point Edwin and Lillian are
talking and they're like well should we
leave you know maybe we should leave
even though they really love this house
and they didn't really want to leave
so they go to bed
and then they hear somebody coming up
the stairs like footsteps coming up the
stairs and then they show this actually
kind of made me laugh a lot because they
show the same ghost again
but I guess like the way they did the
special effect she had you know they had
the actors like in the ghost makeup and
she's all like true you know kind of
transparent and so she's kind of
standing like that but she's just like
you know what I mean like kind of
hovering over it's just like something
about the movement just like really made
me laugh but she's just like whoa here I
come you know what I mean so she's
coming like over the bed and then she
starts attacking Lillian like kind of
shaking her and smacking her around and
[__] like that oh my goodness
so at that point where it starts
attacking Lillian Edwin is like okay
[__] this place we're out of here
um Edwin's like I couldn't really take
seeing her seeing Lillian suffering like
that and being abused like that she's
like we're getting the [__] out of here
so bill was actually happy that they
ended up leaving the house because he
was like I said afraid that they were in
danger
and as I mentioned before Lillian
actually uh at least when this show
aired uh Edward and Lillian were still
together but he said Lillian didn't want
to be on the show because she was still
like scared of what happened there and
she didn't really want to talk about it
um and basically they said I think they
said the ghost was like the ghost that
was causing all the trouble was a former
servant like a servant that had worked
there whose name was Abigail I don't
know if that's true or not
but uh so they basically stayed with
Lillian's sister and then eventually
like moved somewhere else now like I
said three years after they left the
house they were living someplace else
but they said they couldn't bear to park
with the house so they kept it
um but as I said earlier as far as I
know I don't know how long they owned it
after that but it has been sold it's
been it was sold and it was restored and
as far as I know it's for sale again
um I don't think anyone's bought it this
time but it hasn't been for sale that
long like just for a couple of months
but I think that the people that owned
it after them or maybe it was them I'm
not really I wasn't real clear on that
but they would let
like I said they would um I guess for a
fee I would imagine that you could like
spend the night there and do paranormal
investigations and stuff like that
because it is
listed as one of the most haunted houses
in New England you know what I mean so a
lot of groups do want to go in there so
I guess they do let them come in there
like I said probably make them pay I
would imagine because you can't let all
those people like troop through your
house for free that's all I'm saying so
uh so yeah faulty bathtub they drowned a
whole pastel those kids right it's like
what yeah I didn't really get I was like
that's a big thing to bring up and then
not
elaborate on like oh all these kids
drowned on the property I'm like
okay like drowned in what
drowned in molasses
drowned in a puddle where wet I don't
know but they didn't say
and I don't know if there's I mean I'm
sure there's a way you could check
because the I mean the house is famous
it's uh and I even have the address
right here it's for West Broadway in
Gardner Massachusetts
like I said it's been restored it's
still there so
I'm sure you could look up how many
people have died there now I did um
I don't know if this is true but they
said that for a time because like I said
it was a boarding house
I've heard that it was also a brothel
for a short time but I don't know if
that's the case they do say a lot of
that they say that a lot of times about
houses of this era it's like oh for a
while it was a brothel I'm like every
house wasn't a brothel okay but I know
that that is like something that they
say a lot it's a trope yeah so I don't
so I don't know if that's true or not
because the whole thing about that was
that one site I read said that oh like a
prostitute that works there had been
strangled there like and had died there
because like I said I have heard that
there were seven confirmed deaths in
this house including the dude that that
burned burned to death but I I don't
know if that's true or not but like I
said if you know the address I'm sure
it'd like pretty be pretty easy to check
if you have like old newspaper records
and [__] like that
black frog said Jenny just docks to the
ghost
I did sorry sorry ghosts don't come and
punch me
[Laughter]
I'm gonna feel really dumb if like a
ghost shows up tonight and punches me
right in my eye I'll be next to you
though I [__] take care of his ass
you get it you gotta punch him back yeah
got holy water and everything
do you really yeah where'd you get holy
water from
pull it out of my ass I have holy water
but I thought I thought your ass was the
bowels of hell though is that what it is
what are you saying
oh you were saying earlier that your ass
was the bowels of hell oh yeah that too
there's holy water in there oh so it's
like a spigot it's like it's like good
and evil it's whatever I want it to be
it's like hot and cold with the faucet
she's reading too much
that's that's kind of how I do yeah you
know how I do yeah foil's humor just let
this [__] go no no no that's the thing
that well that's what's that's what's
funny to me
is is I like to take um is I like to
take these kind of uh situations and
bring them up to their like
maximum absurdity you know what I mean
that's like [__] hilarious [__]
hilarious yeah uh Ben says this
breakfast cereals are so unhealthy just
pure sugar yeah but you know they're
good
honestly like I said I was into Cookie
Crisp I was into Captain Crunch I would
still eat it now if you had it but it's
like I don't eat breakfast anymore this
is Zach Zach says Tom should get a [__]
stamp with an arrow pointing between his
crack abandoned
Trapster
all the gays would be running from me
okay so good morning well what what
would you tattoo on there like to entice
people into it I have no idea you don't
know I'm not gay as Zach I know but I'm
just wondering I thought exactly able to
I thought you'd be able to come up with
something with some good [__] man I
thought you'd be able to come yeah I
can't I can't Gaya eyes that much again
I can't see it through the gate
he's trying to game imagine
my gay imagination
not as good as sex with some [__]
great [__] well you know be like free
the the arrow be pointing down see like
freed lunch
oh I just thought like those old Looney
Tunes cartoons where they always put
this on it says free beer free beer
[Music]
uh mine would be something like put it
where the sun don't shine that was the
bottom that is okay
Jack your bottom is [__]
oh my God
everything I [__] catch you standing
up in the men's room again I'll [__]
piss at you too you sit the [__] down
when I go in there I'm gonna make a
whole video about that Jen's gonna
[__] play you she's gonna have a POV
Camp look at these abandoned malls or
something and and he's gonna play music
I'm gonna walk in and Zach what the [__]
sit down when I when you see me walking
this [__] you sit the [__] down unless
you standing up pissing around me
the pure male dominance
[Laughter]
that's going to be your whole angle it's
male dominance yeah
everyone else is going to be like yeah
it's subservient yeah yeah everyone
takes the female position
[Laughter]
sit the [__] down that's right
Ben says I have a theory that Roman
gladiator contests were like pro
wrestling most of it was theatrical
[__] doesn't make economic sense
otherwise
um there's something to be said from
that yeah
what happened was and this is according
to Roman history I remember it was
swatonius they said it or whatever but
um
they started making
Roman emperors started making mandates
that dudes had to die in these matches
that there had to be a certain amount of
death matches it's like come on it's no
fun otherwise Gladiators weren't being
killed right what had happened was is
the dudes the Gladiators had become so
valuable
such valuable commodities
that
and they had such huge fan basis and
there must have been secondary markets
for Merch and all kinds of [__] going on
right that they didn't want these dudes
to die if a dude lost they would tend to
be spared
yeah
because is it
you weren't really supposed to fight to
the death that wasn't really part of the
[__] deal in the gladiator fight
you basically had a submission win and
then you'd go to the [__] either the
emperor the MC of the [__] event and
and or the crowd you know should I kill
him or should I let him live
and if he was a coward you were supposed
to kill him if he was Brave you let him
live well these guys had huge fan bases
nobody's going to say the dude was a
coward they had all these [__]
victories and [__] well there were
certain Emperors that were like no no
you would have to make rules some guys
have to die in this or it's not to the
death
uh I don't know how popular yeah it's
like false advertising right
because right yeah people would like buy
tickets people would buy tickets they're
like I thought someone was gonna die
this is [__] right well people did
die yeah but not the the main right
celebrity Gladiators because the the
after the [__] live sex and all that
[__] and the jugglers and the acrobats
you then had animal hunts
which they'd release lines and [__] and
kill them which evidently weren't real
popular with the crowds because a lot of
the [__] especially towards the end it
looked real pitiful the lines looked
like in pitiful health and they really
didn't want to fight and then they were
doing crazy [__] like trying to kill
ostriches and [__] you know killing
elephants and people started to turn
against that
then they would have like um
prisoner executions
they had that
and then they would have battle
reenactments and the battle reenactments
usually were prisoners and the Roman
army fighting prisoners dressed up as
like an enemy and doing a reaction yeah
that's what Ben just said right and um
that was part of your duty as a Roman
soldier to to uh to be in the glass in
the arena and [__] do battle
reenactments kill kill prisoners and
[__]
and then then it was the games
the Gladiators
and they had different ranks you know
the ones that weren't that famous they
got killed a lot
it was just the famous ones the real big
names
they stopped killing those because they
were just worth too much and they were
too popular and the crowds would vote
against vote for their lives you know
what I mean because think about it
if you have Muhammad Ali and Mike Tyson
fighting and [__] Mike Tyson loses
are they really gonna [__] say yeah
you got to kill Mike Tyson they both had
fans you know
it's um
that's all I'm gonna say about yeah
Zach says I'd always heard the best Doms
were little old Asian ladies who get you
to move [__] for them
yeah move [__] into their apartment
[Laughter]
yeah move that TV over there they got a
famous dog shelf over there they got a
famous little Asian Dom in
um [__] uh
the Philippines
and she's got a lot of videos you can
find them like on
xHamster and [__] like that and she's
[__] hilarious all right she's into
bondage and [__] her and her [__]
friend
and they just humiliate dudes but it is
kind of funny you know what they do
these days just
and uh I don't know that's all I'm gonna
say about it I mean I have sex ready you
know I have said before what they would
do to those dudes you know my my love of
those videos of like chicks stepping on
dudes nuts yeah they would do that kind
of stuff and worse you know but they
would like the dudes volunteered for it
yeah that's what I mean it's not like
they just like pulled some Miranda off
the street
so well all the videos they have posted
a lot of them is uh an american guy or a
western guy might be he's he's a
Caucasian he's on there and he's [__]
just jacked as [__] he's a [__]
muscle guy and they just [__] that dude
up
he's out here a lot they just [__] they
do that but it is kind of funny she's
got serious mouth games she could talk
some [__] man and really just I don't
remember her name but [__] just her
[__] talking is [__] the best part of
those videos now I'm gonna have to see
those yeah if I can find him again yeah
that sounds super fun
[Laughter]
you'd like it yeah it probably was yeah
she goes to strap on action and [__]
that dude up and her friends laughing at
him and [__] [__] now he's got
[__] he's a jack dude and he's got
[__] tattoos on him like slave and
[__] and he's you can't see his face
he's got like a box on his head or a
mask you know you can't really [__]
he's tied down
the closer you see is the closest you
see to his face I think he had a little
[__] like a bad mask on yeah there's
that same dude over and over again he's
paying for that right okay oh maybe
that's her boyfriend I don't know
there's no way to know it I mean he's
clearly into it so there's a lot of
videos so maybe he's not paying me he
might live with her right and that's
there yeah that's their stick and you
know it's all in English
and and the the the the videos are an
advertisement for her
Dom service yeah in in uh Philippines
yeah I'm gonna have to look those up
yeah kind of this cute get some pointers
cute overweight Filipino girl who
[__] dominates you with her big ass
rubbing that on your face and all kinds
of weird [__] [__] yeah it's just
funny you know funny
everybody
all right are you ready to wrap it up we
can wrap it up all right so
uh oh I was gonna say so tomorrow I
don't know if we're gonna be streaming
tomorrow because I know it's a holiday
and I'm off and everything like that but
we might be doing
other stuff but I'll let you guys know
anyway but if not uh Wednesday will be
the main show and I'm kind of excited
about this one because this is a topic
I've been wanting to do for a long time
we're doing two
Victorian female murderers okay so we're
going to talk about Mary Piercy all
right and we're going to talk about the
baby farmer Amelia Dyer oh I've been
wanting to do a show about her for a
long time we just mentioned her on
another show yeah we haven't done a
whole show that was probably the most
evil woman in history
she's [__] evil although no there are
a lot of other evil ones yeah I mean
that's kind of like a hard yeah ranking
to make but some of those serial killer
girlfriends did for Wicked [__] too well
16 year old girls dig their own Graves
and then [__] kill them and [__]
after she had raped him her and her and
her [__] boyfriend that was we got to
do it we got to do a show on them
yeah that old big old fat redneck and
his girlfriend
yeah cause I know yeah if we used to do
um a lot of like killer couples shows
but we might yeah she got off I don't
think we've covered them she got off I
don't think she did any prison time
because she claimed that well I was
scared of him right it was one of those
guys back in the 80s
yeah did we do it like because I know
that we did because remember we used to
do every Valentine's Day we always used
to do a killer couple show yeah and we
did we do several of them we would do
like three or four of them on each show
or I think she got off she virtually got
off she testified against him and yeah I
got a light sentence or got off when I
don't remember but that's but yeah so
that's what Wednesday's show is going to
be about the and I'm kind of I'm not you
know excited about it because I've been
wanting to do that show for a long time
so finally won in the damn pole when I
was very very happy American Military is
asking you something uh are you ever
gonna review the folk horror film eyes
of fire 1983. I thought I did
um I'd have to go back and look I'm
pretty I thought I did a flickers of
fear about it because I remember
watching it not too long ago because
shutter remember had that um that three
and a half hour like folk horror
documentary
and they mentioned eyes of fire on there
and they had that on there too and I
watched it and I thought I did a video
of it and if I didn't then
I must be crazy because I'm pretty sure
I did one but I don't remember it no I
think I just watched I just okay she did
solo yeah but I'm pretty sure I'll have
to look but I'm pretty sure I did it uh
Ben said she claimed she actually
adopted he's talking about uh Amelia
Dyer claims she actually adopted out all
the babies didn't she yeah I think at
first she kind of did but then like
after a while she's like you know what
it'd be much easier just to like [__]
strangle him yeah she threw them [__]
into the Thames yeah she threw those
babies into the town yeah and they are
not actually sure how many killed 100 of
them
um they think uh it was between 200 and
400. okay right right but um they're not
entirely sure yeah like I think she just
got convicted of six that they knew of
you know what I mean but they speculate
just because of
you know how many people were missing
and [__] like that that it might have
been as many as 400
so yeah
uh not not great but yeah that's good
what the show's gonna be about Wednesday
night so if you are in the United States
please have a good Fourth of July
tomorrow please don't blow off any of
your appendages with fireworks yeah yeah
um that would be bad don't set anything
on fire don't set your house on fire or
anything like that so uh so yeah we'll
see you guys on Wednesday night good
night